قناه رئيس التركيه رجب طيب اردوغان انه
يعمل على جعل بلاده مركزا عالميا لتوزيع
الطاقه والغاز الطبيعي
وتوفير استثمارات لتخفيف اثار ازمه الطاقه
الرئيس التركي في افتتاح مخزن للغاز
الطبيعي
ويوصف بانه الاكبر في اوروبا
سنعمل على جعل تركيا مركز عالميا يتم فيه
تحديد اسعار الغاز الطبيعي في العالم وقد
حصلت تطورات ايجابيه خلال المباحثات التي
اجريناها مع السيد بوتين وبفضل ذلك ستكون
منطقه تراكيا شمال غربيه البلاد مركزا
للطاقه في العالم
مع الدول الشركه لنا في المنطقه في مجال
الطاقه ومدركون ان الانزعاج الحاصله لدى
بعض الاطراف من تطوير علاقاتنا مع ليبيا
على مبدا المنفعه المشتركه للبلدين تنبع
منزعجهم من الخطوات التركيه